the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so last time was orthogonal matrices Q
and this time is symmetric matrices s so
we're really talking about the best
matrices of all well I'll start with any
square matrix and about eigenvectors but
you've heard of eigenvectors more than
more than once more than twice more than
ten times probably okay so eigenvectors
and then let's be sure we know why
they're useful and maybe compute one or
two but then we'll move to symmetric
matrices and what is special about those
and then even more special and more
important will be positive definite
symmetric matrices so that when I say
positive definite I mean symmetric so
start with a next comes s then come the
special s special symmetric matrices
that have this extra positive definite
property ok so start with a so an
eigenvector if i multiply a by x I get
some vector and sometimes if X is
especially chosen well ax comes out in
the same direction as X ax comes out
some number times X so there are
normally there would be for an N by n
matrix so let's let's say an a is n by n
today
normally if we're if we live right there
will be n different independent vectors
X Augen vectors that have this special
property and we can compute them by hand
if n is 2 or 3 to mostly but the
computation of the X's and the lambda so
this is this is for I equal 1 up to n if
I use this sort of math shorthand that I
have n of these almost always and my
first question is what are they good for
well why why do just course after course
introduced eigenvectors and to me the
key property is seen by looking at a
squared so let me look at a squared so
it's another N by n matrix and we would
ask suppose we know these guys
suppose we found those somehow what
about a squared is X an eigen vector of
a squared also well the way to find out
is to multiply a squared by X and see
what happens do you see what's going to
happen here this is a times ax which is
a times ax is lambda X and and now what
what do I do now because I'm shooting
for the answer yes x is an eigenvector
of a squared also so what do I do that
number that lambda is just a number
that's I can put it anywhere I like so I
can put it out front and then I have a X
which is lambda X thanks so I have
another lambda X so as lambda squared X
so I learned the crucial thing here that
X is also an I
vector of a-squared and the eigenvalue
is lambda squared and of course I can
keep going so a to the end X is lambda
to the end X we have found the right
vectors for that particular matrix a
what about a inverse X that will be if
everything is good one over lambda X
well yeah so anytime I write 1 over
lambda my mind says what you've got to
like make some comment on the special
case where it doesn't work which is yeah
if lambda is not 0 I'm golden if lambda
is 0 it doesn't look good and but what's
happening if lambda is 0 hey doesn't
even have an inverse if lambda was 0
which it could be no no no rule against
it if lambda was 0 this would say a
times the eigenvector is 0 times the
eigenvector so that would tell me that
the eigenvector is in the null space it
would tell me that the matrix a isn't
invertible it's taking some vector X to
0 and so so the everything clicks this
works when it should work and if we have
other font any function of the matrix we
could define the exponential of a matrix
18:03 would do that let's just let's
just write it down as if we know what it
means it does it have the same eigen
vector well sure because e to the a T
exponential of a matrix if I see either
there's something I think of that long
infinite series that gives the
exponential those all the terms in that
series are have powers of a so
everything is working every term in that
series x is an eigenvector and when I
it all together I learned that the
eigenvalue is e to the lambda T that's
just a typical and and and successful
work use okay so that's I can vectors
and eigen values and and we'll find some
in a minute now so I'm claiming that
this is the this that from this first
thing which was just like about certain
vectors are special now we're beginning
to see why there why they're useful so
special is good useful is even better so
so let me take take any vector say V and
okay what do I want to do I want to use
eigen vectors this V is probably not an
eigen vector but I'm supposing that I've
got n of them you and I are agreed that
there are some matrices for which there
are not a full set of eigen vectors
that's really the the main sort of
annoying point in the whole subject of
linear algebra as some matrices don't
have enough eigenvectors but almost all
do and let's go forward assuming our
matrix has okay so if I've got n
independent eigenvectors that's a basis
I can write any vector V as a
combination of those eigen vectors right
and then I can find out what a to the to
any power so that's the point that this
is this is going to be simple and and
the reason why we like to have we like
to know the eigen vectors because if I
choose
as my basis vectors V is a combination
of them now if I multiply by a or a
squared or a to the K power then it's
linear so I can multiply each one by a
to the K and what do I get if I multiply
that guy by a to the K power okay well
I'm just gonna use or here I set in but
let me say K and I'm sorry I'm using n
for the size of the matrix so I better
use K for the for the typical case here
so what do I get
just to help me through this and and
we're happy oh so what happens when I
multiply that by a to the K it's an
eigenvector remember so when I multiply
by a to the K I get c1 that's just a
number and a to the K times that eigen
vector gives lambda 1 to the K times the
eigenvector right that's the whole point
and linearity says keep going C n lambda
n to the K power X and in other words I
have I can take I can apply any power of
a matrix I can apply the exponential of
a matrix I can do anything quickly
because I've got the eigen vector so
really so I'm saying the first use for
eigen vectors may be the principle use
for which they were invented is to be
able to solve difference equations so so
this so let me if I call that VK the
case power then the equation I'm solving
here is a one-step difference equation
this is my difference equation and if I
wanted to use Exponential's the equation
I would be solving with
DVD T equals a these solution to
discrete steps or continuous time
evolution comes is trivial if I know the
eigenvectors because here's the solution
to this one and the solution to this one
is the same thing c1 e to the lambda 1t
x1 is that what you were expecting for
the for the solution here because if I
take the derivative it brings down a
lambda if I multiply by a it brings down
the lambda so plus the other guys okay
not news but important to remember what
eigenvectors are for in the first place
good yeah let me move ahead
oh one one matrix
fact is about something called similar
matrices so I have on my matrix a then I
have the idea of what it means to be
similar to a so B is similar to a or
yeah what does that mean so here's
here's what it means first of all it
means that B can be found from a by this
is the key operation here multiplying by
a matrix M and its inverse M inverse am
when I see two matrices B an A
that are connected by that kind of a
change M could be any invertible matrix
then I would say be with similar day and
that changed that that that appearance
of M is pretty natural if I change
variables here by M then I get that
similar matrix will show up so what's
the key fact do you remember the key
fact about similar matrices if B and a
are connected like that they have the
same eigenvalues so this is a just a
useful point to remember so I'll this is
like one fact in the in the discussion
of eigenvalues and eigenvectors so
similar matrices same eigenvalues
yeah so in in some way in the eigenvalue
eigenvector world they're there in this
they belong together they they're
connected by is by this relation that
just turns out to be the right thing
actually that is it gives us a clue of
how eigenvalues are actually computed
well they're actually computed by typing
I of a with parentheses around a that's
how they're in in real life but what
happens when you type I give a well you
could say the eigenvalue shows up on the
screen but something had to happen in
there
and what happened it was that MATLAB or
whoever took that matrix a started using
good choices of M better and better you
know took a bunch of steps with
different M's because if I do another M
I still have a similar matrix right if I
if I take B and do a different M 2 to B
so I get something similar to B then
that's also similar to way I've got a
whole family of similar things there and
what does it what does MATLAB do with
all these M's and 1 and M 2 and M 3 and
so on it brings the matrix to triangular
matrix
it gets the eigenvalues showing up on
the diagonal it's just tremendously it
was the inspiration when that when there
when the good choice of M appeared and
let me just say because I'm going on to
symmetric matrices that for symmetric
matrices everything is sort of cleaned
you're not you not only go to
triangular matrix you go to it toward a
diagonal matrix they off tire you you
choose M's that make the off-diagonal
stuff smaller and smaller and smaller
and the eigenvalues are not changing so
they're shooting up on the diagonal are
the eigenvalues so I guess I should
verify that fact that similar matrices
have the same eigen values can be there
can't be much to show we can't be much
in the proof because that's all I know
and I want to know its eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so let me say suppose m
inverse a m has the eigen vector Y and
the eigen value lambda and I want to
show do I want to show that Y is an
eigen vector also of a itself no
eigenvectors are changing do I want to
show that lambda is an eigenvalue of a
itself yes that's my point so can we see
that huh can I see that lambda is an
eigenvalue there's like there's not a
lot to do here I mean if I can't do it
soon I'm never going to do it because so
what am I going to do yeah I could yeah
X is my is going to be a key and I can
see my coming just when I see M inverse
over there or what am I going to do with
the darn thing I'm gonna put it on the
other side I'm gonna multiply that
equation by M so I'll have that we'll
put the M over here and I'll have a M y
equals lambda M Y right and is that
telling me what I want to know yes
that's saying that my that you wisely
suggested to given name x2 is lambda
times my do you see that that
that the eigen value lambda didn't
change the eigenvector did change it
changed from Y to my that's the X the
eigenvector of X this is lambda X yeah
so that's the role of M it just it just
gives you a different basis for
eigenvectors but it does not change
eigen values right yeah okay so those
are similar matrices yeah some other
good things happened a lot of people
don't know in fact I wasn't like very
conscious of the fact that a times B has
the same eigen values as B times a well
I'm you I should maybe write that down a
B has the same eigen values the same
nonzero once you know you'll see I have
two as be a this is any a and B same
size I'm not talking similar matrices
here I'm talking any two a and B yeah so
that's a good thing that happens now
could we could we see one and then I'm
gonna be really pretty happy with basic
facts about eigen values so so if I want
to show that two things have the same
eigen values what what do you propose
show that they are similar I already
said if they're similar so is there an M
is there an M that will connect this
matrix so is there an M that will
multiply this matrix that way so that
would be similar to a B and can I
produce B a then
so I'll just put the word want up here I
want if I if I have that then I'm done
because that's saying that those two
matrices a B and BA are similar and I
know that then they have the same
eigenvalues so are they what should mb m
should be so what does I am here I want
that to be true should mb be yeah a me
will be boy not the most hidden fact
here take take m equal B so then I've B
times a times B B inverse which is the
identity so I have B time say yes okay
so so a b-and-b a are fine no what do
you think about this question are the
eigen rows I now know that a B & B a of
the same eigen values and the reason I
had to be careful about non zero is that
if I had zero eigen values then yeah I I
can't count on those inverses right
right so so that's why I put in that
little qualifier but now I want to ask
this question if I know the eigenvalues
of a separately by itself a and of B now
I'm talking about any two matrices a and
B if if I have two matrices a and I have
a matrix a and a matrix B and I know
those are I can values in their
eigenvalues what about a B a times B can
I multiply the eigenvalues of a time's
the eigenvalues of b
don't do it right yes right eigen values
of a times the eigen values of B could
be damn near anything right they're not
connected to the eigen values of a B
especially in maybe some something could
be discovered but not much and similarly
for a plus B that so yeah so so let me
just write down this point I give values
of a plus B are generally not eigen
values of a plus I in values of be
generally not just there's no reason and
they're the reason that that's I get
that no answer is the eigen vectors can
be all different if the eigen vectors
for a are totally different from the
eigen vectors for B then a plus B will
have probably some other totally
different eigen vectors and there's
nothing nothing happening there there's
that sort of a thoughts about eigen
values in general and I could there be a
whole section on eigen vectors but I'm
really interested in eigenvectors of
symmetric matrices so I'm going to move
on to that topic so now having talked
about any matrix a I'm gonna specialize
to symmetric matrices see what's special
about the eigenvalues are there what's
special about the eigenvectors there and
i think we've already said it in class
so let me let me ask you to tell me
about it tell me again so I'll call that
matrix s now as a reminder always that
I'm talking here about symmetric
matrices so what do i what are the key
facts to know I can values are real
real numbers if the matrix is I'm
thinking of real symmetric matrices of
course other real matrices could have
imaginary eigenvalues other real major
so just let's just think for a moment
yeah maybe I'll just put it here can I
back up before I keep going with
symmetric matrices so so take a matrix
like like like that Q yeah that would be
a Q but it's not specially a Q maybe the
maybe the most remarkable thing about
that matrix is that it's anti-symmetric
so I'll call it a for right if I
transpose that matrix what do I get
there negative so that's like anti
symmetric and I claim that an anti
symmetric matrix has imaginary
eigenvalues so that's a that's a that's
a 90 degree rotation and you might say
what could be simpler than that a 90
degree rotation that's not a weird
matrix but from the point of view of
eigenvectors some things little odd has
to happen right because if I have a 90
degree rotation if I take a vector X any
vector X could it possibly be an
eigenvector well apply a to it you'd be
off in this direction a X and there is
no way that a X can be a multiple of X
so there's no real eigenvector for that
for that anti-symmetric matrix or any
anti symmetric matrix yep so you see
that when we say that the eigenvalues of
a symmetric matrix are real we're saying
that this couldn't happen that this
couldn't happen if they were symmetric
and here it's a very opposite it's
antisymmetric well well that's on the
board you might say wait a minute how
could that have any eigenvector
whatsoever so what is an eigenvector of
that matrix a how do you find the
eigenvectors of a when they're two by
two that's a calculation we know how to
do you remember the steps there I'm
looking for ax equal lambda X so right
now I'm looking for both lambda annex
I've got two
that's not linear but I'm gonna bring
this over to this side and write it as a
minus lambda I X equal to zero and then
I'm gonna look at that and say wow a
minus lambda I must be not invertible
because it's got this X in its null
space so the determinant of this matrix
must be zero I couldn't have a null
space and that's the determinant is zero
and then when I look at a minus lambda I
for this a I've got minus lambdas - hey
oh it's just a one and that's minus one
I'm gonna take the determinant and what
am I going to get for the determinant
lambda squared plus one and I set that
to zero
so I'm just following all the rules but
it's showing me that the lambda the two
lambdas there are two lambdas here but
they're not real because that equation
the roots are I and minus I so those are
the eigenvalues and they have the nice
they have all the well they are the
eigenvalues no doubt about it with
two-by-two there are two quick checks
that tell you yeah you did the
calculation right if I add up the two
eigenvalues in this if I add up the two
eigenvalues for any matrix and I'm going
to do it for this one I get what answer
I get the same answer from the adding
add the add the lambdas gives me the
same answer as add the diagonal of the
matrix which I'm calling a so if I add
the diagonal I get zero and zero so it's
zero plus zero and this number adding
the diagonal is called the trace and
we'll see it again because it's so
simple just adding the diagonal entries
gives you a key bit of information when
you add down the diagonal it tells you
the sum of the eigen value lambda it
doesn't tell you each lambda separately
but it tells you the sum so it tells you
one fact by doing one thing yeah so
that's pretty handy gives you a quick
check if you've you know bike when you
compute this determinant and solve for
lambda
the thing you this is a way to compute
eigenvalues by hand you could make a
mistake because it's a quadratic formula
for 2x2 but you can check by adding the
two roots do you get the same as the
trace 0 plus 0 well there's one other
check equally quick for 2 by 2 so 2 by 2
is you really get them right what's the
other check 2 we add the eigen values we
get the trace we multiply the eigen
values so we take so so now I'll
multiply the lambdas so then I get I
times minus I and that should equal
let's don't look yet what should it
equal if I multiply the eigen values I
should get the determinant right of a so
that's 2 handy checks add the eigen
values for any size 3 by 3 4 by 4 but
it's only 2 checks
so 4 2 by 2 it's kind of you got it 3 by
3 4 by 4 you could still have made an
error and the two checks could
potentially still work let's just check
it out here what's I times minus I 1
because it's minus I squared and that's
plus 1 and the determinant of that
matrix is 0 minus is 1 yep
ok so we got one good those are really
the key facts about eigenvalues but of
course the they're not it's not as
simple as solving ax equal B to find
them but it's if you follow
on this idea of similar matrices and
sort of chopped down the off-diagonal
part then sure enough the eigenvalues
got to show up okay
symmetric symmetric matrices okay so now
we're going to have symmetric and then
we'll have the special even better than
symmetric is symmetric positive-definite
okay symmetric you told me the main
facts are the eigenvalues real the eigen
vectors orthogonal and I guess actually
yeah so I want to put the take to put
those into math symbols instead of words
so yeah yeah I guess yeah shall I just
jump in and the other other thing hidden
there but but very important is there's
a full set of eigenvectors even if some
eigenvalues happen to be repeated like
the identity matrix it still got plenty
of eigenvectors so that's an added point
that I'm not made there and I'll I could
prove those two statements but why don't
I ask you to accept them and go onward
what are we gonna do with them okay and
yeah
okay can you just like let's have an
example just up let me put an example
here suppose s non calling it s is zeros
1 & 1 so that's symmetric what are its
eigenvalues what are the eigenvalues of
that symmetric matrix s plus and minus 1
well if you propose to eigenvalues I'll
write them down 1 and minus 1 and then
what will I do to check them trace and
determinant ok so are they or is it true
that the eigenvalues are 1 and minus 1
okay how do I check the trace what is
the trace of that matrix 0 and what's
the sum of the eigenvalues 0 good what
about determinate what's the determinant
of s minus 1 the product of the
eigenvalues minus 1 so we've got it ok
what are the eigenvectors what vector
can you multiply by and it doesn't
change direction in fact doesn't change
at all i'm looking for the eigenvector
that's a steady state 0 1
I think it's 1 1 yeah so here's the
lambdas and then the eigenvectors are I
think 1 1 is that right yeah sure SS is
just a permutation here it's just
exchanging the two entries so one on one
won't change and what what's the other
eigenvector 1 and minus 1
and then I'm thinking remembering about
this similar stuff I'm thinking that a s
is similar to a matrix that just shows
the eigenvalues so s is similar to I'm
going to put in an M well I'm going to
connect s that matrix with the
eigenvalue matrix which has the
eigenvalues so here's my everybody calls
that matrix capital lambda because
everybody calls the eigenvalues little
lambda so the matrix that has them is
called capital lambda and I my claim is
that these guys are similar that this
matrix s that you're seeing up there I
believe there's an M I believe there's
an M so that s what did I put in here so
I'm following this pattern I believe
that there would be an M and an M
inverse so that this would mean that and
that's nice first of all it's it would
confirm that the eigenvalues stay the
same which which which was certain to
happen and then it would also mean that
I had got a diagonal matrix and of
course that's a natural goal to get a
diagonal matrix so we might hope that
the M that gets us there is like an
important matrix so do you see what I'm
doing here it comes under the heading of
diagonalizing a matrix I start with a
matrix s I find its eigenvalues they go
on into lambda and I believe I can find
an M so that I see there they're similar
they have the same eigen values 1 and -1
both sides so only
in question is what's in what's the
matrix that diagonalizes s the what have
we got left to use the eigenvectors the
matrix that so can I put the M like over
there yeah I'll put that ember inverse
is going to go over to the other side oh
it goes here doesn't involve us I was
like worried there I didn't look good
but yeah so so this is all going to be
right if if this is what I'd like to
have SI m equal m lambda s m equal m
lambda
that's diagonalizing a matrix that's
finding the m using the eigenvectors
that produces a similar matrix lambda
which has the eigenvalues that that's
that's the great fact about
diagonalizing that's how you use that's
another way to say this is how the
eigenvectors pay off you put them into m
you take the similar matrix and it's
nice and diagonal and do you see that
this will happen s time so M has the
first eigen vector and the second eigen
vector and I believe that the first
eigenvector x the second at end the
second eigenvector that's am again on
this side no me just write in the 1 0 0
minus 1 I believe this got to be like
confirming that we've done their thing
right confirming that the eigen vectors
work here could just like please make
sense out of that last line when you see
that last line how what do I mean to
make sense out of it what I want to see
that that's true how do I see that
how do I do this so what's the left side
and what's the right side so what if if
I multiply s by a couple of columns
what's the answer
SX 1 and s x2 that's the beauty of
matrix multiplication if I multiply a
matrix by another matrix I can do it a
column at a time there there are four
great ways to multiply matrices so this
is another one a column at a time so
this left hand side is SX 1
SX - I just do each column and what
about the right hand side I can do that
multiplication X 1 minus X 2 did
somebody say death no I don't want oh
excuse ed it right ok when you say next
1 minus X 2 I was subtracting but you
meant that that's the first column is X
1 and the second column is minus X 2
correct sorry about that and did we come
out right yes because now I compare SX 1
is lambda 1 X 1s X 2 is lambda 2 X 2 and
I'm golden so what was the point of this
board what did we learn we learned well
we kind of expected that the original s
would be similar to the lambdas because
the eigen values match s has eigen
values lambda and this diagonal matrix
certainly has eigen values 1 and minus 1
a diagonal matrix the eigen values are
right in front of you so they're similar
s is similar to the lambda and there
should be an M and then somebody
suggested maybe the M is the
eigenvectors and that's the right answer
so finally let me write that
in here which isn't just for symmetric
so maybe I should put it for matrix a so
if it has lambdas and eigenvectors and
the claim is that a time's the
eigenvector matrix is the eigenvector
matrix times the eigenvalues and i would
shorten that to a x equals x lambda and
i could rewrite that and then i'll slow
down as a equal x lambda X inverse
really this is bringing it all together
in a simple small formula it's telling
us that a is similar to lambda it's
telling us the matrix M that does the
job it's the matrix of eigenvectors and
so it's like a shorthand way to write
what right the main facts about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors what about
a squared can I go back to the very
first IC time as close to the end here
what about a squared what are the
eigenvectors of a squared what are the
eigenvalues of a squared that's like the
whole point of eigenvalues well or I
could just square that stupid thing X
lambda X inverse X lambda X inverse and
what have I got X inverse X in the
middle is identity so I have X lambda
squared X inverse and to me that unto
you that says
the item values have been squared the
eigenvectors didn't change yeah okay and
now finally last breath is what if the
matrix is symmetric then we have
different letters that's the only that's
a significant change the eigenvector
matrix is now an orthogonal matrix I'm
coming back to the key facts of what
makes symmetric how do I read how do I
see symmetric helping me in the eigen
vector and eigen value world well it
tells me that the eigenvectors are
orthogonal so the X is Q the eigenvalues
are real and the eigenvectors is x
inverse but now I'm going to make those
eigenvectors and unit vectors I'm going
to normalize it so I'm really allowing I
have an orthogonal matrix Q so I have a
different way to write this and this is
the end of the today's class Q lambda
and what's what can you tell me about Q
inverse it's Q transpose thanks so that
was the last lecture so now the
orthogonal lecture is coming up at the
last second of the symmetric matrices
lecture and this has the name spectral
theorem which I just put there and whole
point is that it tells you what every
symmetric matrix looks like orthogonal
eigenvectors real eigenvalues